Now I have a question.
>> This is Psalms 83 and 18.
>> It says that men may know that thou
whose name alone is Yhovah. Jehovah, we
would say Yahawah
are the most high all over all the
earth. How many names is the most high
according to that verse?
>> How many names? You mean one name?
Yahweh. Is that what you're asking me?
What do you mean? How many names?
>> How many? According to that verse, it
says, "Thou whose name alone,"
>> you said, "What?
>> Yahweh, Jehovah, Yahweh."
>> Okay. So, is there any other most highs
according to that verse? Are there any
>> I'm sorry. Are there any other most
highs?
>> Yeah. No, there's no job. Okay. Now, can
I articulate my position?
>> Wait, I just want you to say that again.
You said there's only Yahawah, right? As
the Most High Yahawasha. Yeah. Yahawah.
Yahawasha.
>> No. No. Yahawah is the So I'm I'm going
to give you the floor. I just want for
the record. This man just said only
Yahawah is the most high over all the
earth. Debate over. [laughter]
>> Okay, let's see what's over. Now it says
>> you're worse than William. I just want
you to know you way you worse than
William and you're worse than William
and inspiring philosophy. You're worse
than both of them.
>> Now, can I answer you? I know you're
manifesting because if you really knew
my position, you're just bearing your
fake god under the feet of Jesus. Our
position is that Jesus is Yahawah.
[laughter]
Let me show you now.
Manifest that demon in you. Hold on one
second. Let's see if you can be honest.
Let's see. All right. So guys, I want
you to see this guy is one of the worst
anti-trinitarians on the planet. Why?
Because he thinks that the father alone
is Jehovah. When our position is that
Yahwah, Jehovah, is the trinity. But I'm
going to show it to you.
Okay,
let me manifest like you. All right.
Isaiah 40:es 3-5.
World's smallest violin. The voice of
him that crith in the wilderness,
"Prepare ye the way of the Lord. Make
straight in the desert a highway for
God." Now, I want you to see the funeral
here. The voice is preparing for the
Lord Yahwh Jehovah, for our God, the God
of Israel, not a creature. Every valley
shall be exalted, and every mountain and
hill shall be made low, and the crooked
shall be made straight, and the rough
places plain, and the glory of the Lord
Yahwa shall be revealed, and all flesh
shall see it together, for the mouth of
the Lord Yahweh, hath spoken it. Now,
watch the funeral. I mean, now this is
the cremation. John 19:34. And this is
the record of John when the Jews sent
priests and Levites from Jerusalem to
ask him, who art thou? And he confessed
and denied not, but confessed, I am not
the Christ. They asked him, What then
art thou Elias? And he saith, I am not.
Art thou that prophet? And he answered,
No. Then said they unto him, Who art
thou? That we may give an answer to them
that sent us. What sayest thou of
thyself? He said, I am the voice of one
crying in the wilderness, make straight
the way of the Lord, as said the prophet
Isaiah. So guys, in case you missed it,
taking time because I'm trying to make
connection with scriptures, semantics as
he called it. The voice of him that
crith in the wilderness, prepare ye the
way of the Lord, not a creature, not an
agent, because John is the agent. Make
straight in the desert a highway for our
God. So Yahweh our God, Yahweh our God,
that's who the voice is preparing. Every
valley shall be exalted, every mountain
and hill shall be made low, and the
crooked shall be made straight, and the
rough places plain. The glory of the
Lord Yahweh shall be revealed, and all
flesh shall see it together. For the
mouth of the Lord, Yahweh hath spoken.
So who is John? John, who are you? He
said, I am the voice of one crying in
the wilderness, make straight the way of
the Lord, as said the prophet Isaiah. So
John is the one who is going to prepare
for the coming of Yahawah our God. Now
John, who is that Yahwh? Who is that
Jehovah? Is it the father? And they
which were sent were the Pharisees. And
they asked him and said unto him, Why
baptize thou then if thou be not the
Christ, nor Elias, neither that prophet?
John answered them, saying, I baptize
with water, but there standeth one among
you whom you know not. He he it is who
coming after me is preferred before me,
whose shoes latcheth, I'm not worthy to
unloose. These things were done in
Bethabara beyond Jordan where John was
baptizing. The next day John seeth Jesus
coming to him and saith, Behold the Lamb
of God which take away the sin of the
world. This is he of whom I said after
me cometh a man which is preferred
before me for he was before me and I
knew him not but that he should be made
manifest Israel. Therefore am I come
baptizing with water. And John bare
record, saying, I saw the Spirit from
heaven, descending from him like a dove,
and a boat upon him, and I knew him not.
But he that sent me to baptize with
water, the same said unto me, upon whom
thou shalt see the spirit descending
remain on him, the same is he which
baptizeth with the Holy Ghost, and I saw
and bear record that this is Son of God.
So now, let's see if you can answer the
question. Clearly, John knows Jesus is
the son of God. He's not the father. And
he clearly knows he's not the Holy
Spirit. He's the one baptized with the
Holy Spirit. But John says, "I'm the
voice preparing people not for the
coming of a creature, an agent." John is
the agent. I'm preparing for Yahawah,
our God. And he says, "Jesus is the one
I prepared for." So he's not a Unitarian
like you. He's a trinitarian because he
identified Jesus the son who is Yahwa.
And therefore, Psalm 83:18 proves he's
the most high. Refute the ex Jesus. Cap.
I'm going to add a scripture to what you
brought out in Isaiah in Malachi 4
and five. I'm sorry, Malachi. Yeah,
Malachi 4 and5 says, "Behold, I will
send you Elijah the prophet before the
coming of the great dreadful day of the
Lord, which is also um talk about John."
We know that John was Elijah. So when it
says before the great coming and
dreadful day of the Lord when John came
the great and dreadful day of the Lord
did not come. Why? Because there was a
process to it. And the process is very
simple. John prepared the way for Christ
to then do his job because he was also
sent to do a job. That's not making him
the most high. He was doing the job of
his father. As he consistently said
throughout the text, I do the works of
my father. This subject is not about the
works that Christ did. This subject is
not about John prepared a way for Christ
to also prepare the way for us to repent
and serve the most high in the end. The
subject of this debate is is Jesus the
most high? That's the subject. He has
yet to substantiate that subject, but
has, like I said, done everything to
make a semantic argument. So, now I've
answered your question.
>> I'm going to jump to Philippians 2, but
I'm going to follow your trajectory. So,
be patient. I'm going to now use Malachi
to butcher your fake God and Philippians
2 to further cremate him. You went to
Malachi 4. Now, let's go to Malachi 3:1.
Behold, I send my messenger. He shall
prepare the way before me. Now, I want
you to pay attention. I'm going to
answer Philippians 2. Just be patient
because I'm jumping with you. When you
jump to a text, I'll jump to that same
book to show you why your God is fake.
Okay? Behold, I'll send my messenger and
he shall prepare the way before me.
Remember this language, Cap? Me. Now,
you agree God is speaking, right?
God is speaking, right? I don't need to
convince you of that. Correct?
Uh when God is always angels or
messengers speaking for the most high
sayaith the Lord of hosts I have to
convince you
>> right when it says sayith the Lord of
hosts that's an angel quoting the most
high correct
>> okay we'll go with that the Lord whom
you see shall suddenly come to his
temple so the temple belongs to who cap
>> the most high
>> good guys I want you to hear this I send
my messenger and he shall prepare the
way before me the Lord whom whom you
seek shall suddenly come to his temple.
Even the messenger of the covenant, the
angel of the covenant whom you delight
in, behold, he shall come, sayith the
Lord of hosts, my messenger will prepare
the way before me. And then the Lord
will come to his temple. Jesus quotes
this in Matthew 11:10 about John. Luke
7:27 and Mark 1 does. Now, let's see who
that messenger was. For this is he of
whom it is written, "Behold, I send my
messenger before thy face, which shall
prepare thy way before thee." So Jesus
said,
>> "I'm sorry, my phone is not on vibrator.
I apologize."
>> That's fine.
Okay. Ready?
>> Yeah, I'm ready. Go ahead.
>> For Jesus said, Matthew 11, it's about
John. Jesus said, "Behold this, he John
is the one." When [clears throat]
Malachi said, "I send my messenger
before thy face, which shall prepare thy
way before thee." Now cap, I want you to
see the change of pronouns. Watch what
Jesus did. I want to see if you because
semantics. You're saying I'm playing
games. I will send my messenger. He
shall prepare the way before me.
>> Here when Jesus quotes it, the me, the
me is now. I will send my messenger
before thy face, your face, which shall
prepare thy way before thee. So Jesus
said John is the messenger. He sent by
the father to prepare my way. But you
just admit that the one that's going to
come is the Lord to his temple. That's
the most high. Jesus says that John was
sent to prepare for my coming, which
means I'm the Lord who owns the temple.
You just buried yourself because that
means Jesus is the most high.
Oh, now before you go on to your
preaching, let me repeat again. I want
to see if you can do ex Jesus. I'm using
your King James Bible. Behold, I send my
messenger before thy face. Jesus
deliberately changed the pronoun.
Because here it's behold, I send a
messenger before me. The my and the me
is the one God. But here Jesus breaks it
down to show that the my and me is the
two persons who are the most high, the
father and the son. So John was sent to
prepare for the coming of Jehovah, the
Lord to his temple, which you said is
the most high. And Jesus says, "I'm that
one." And John says, "That's the one.
This is your burial cap.